We will now go through
an example that
involves a continuous
unknown parameter,
the unknown bias of a coin
and discrete observations,
namely, the number
of heads that are
observed in a sequence
of coin flips.
This is an example that we
will start in some detail now,
and we will also
revisit later on.
And in the process, we will
also have the opportunity
to introduce a new class of
probability distributions.
This example is an
extension of an example
that we have already
seen, when we first
introduced the relevant
version of the Bayes rule.
We have a coin.
It has a certain bias between 0
and 1, but the bias is unknown.
And consistent with the
Bayesian philosophy,
we treat this unknown
bias as a random variable,
and we assign a prior
probability distribution to it.
We flip this coin n
times independently,
where n is some
positive integer,
and we record the number
of heads that are obtained.
On the basis of the value
of this random variable,
we would like to make
inferences about Theta.
Now to make some more
concrete progress,
let us make a
specific assumption.
Let us assume that
the prior on Theta
is uniform on the unit interval,
in some sense reflecting
complete ignorance about
the true value of Theta.
We observe the value of this
random variable, some little k,
we fix that value, and we're
interested in the functional
dependence on theta of
this particular quantity,
when k is given to us.
How do we do this?
We use the appropriate form
of the Bayes rule, which
in this setting is as follows.
it is the usual
form, but we have
f's indicating
densities whenever we're
talking about the
distribution of Theta,
because Theta is continuous.
And whenever we talk about
the distribution of K, which
is discrete, we
use the symbol p,
because we're dealing with
probability mass functions.
As always, the
denominator term is such
that the integral of the
whole expression over theta
is equal to 1.
This is the necessary
normalization property,
and because of this,
this denominator term
has to be equal to the
integral of the numerator
over all theta, which
is what we have here.
So now let us move, and
let us apply this formula.
We first have the prior,
which is equal to 1.
Then we have the probability
that K is equal to little k.
This is the probability of
obtaining exactly k heads,
if I tell you the
bias or the coin.
But if I tell you
the bias of the coin,
we're dealing with the usual
model of independent coin
flips, and the
probability of k heads
is given by the binomial
probabilities, which
takes this form.
And finally, we have
the denominator term,
which we do not need to
evaluate at this point.
Now, I said earlier that we're
interested in the dependence
on theta, which comes
through these terms.
On the other hand,
the remaining terms
do not involve any
thetas, and so they
can be lumped together
in just a constant.
And so we can write
the answer that we
have found in this
more suggestive form.
We have some
normalizing constant,
and here we keep separately
the dependence on theta.
Of course, this
answer that we derived
is valid for little theta
belonging to the unit interval.
Outside the unit interval,
either the prior density
or the posterior density of
Theta would be equal to 0.
This particular form of
the posterior distribution
for Theta is a certain
type of density,
and it shows up in
various contexts.
And for this reason,
it has a name.
It is called a Beta distribution
with certain parameters,
and the parameters
reflect the exponents
that we have up here
in the two terms.
Note that these parameters are
the exponents augmented by 1.
This is for historical reasons
that do not concern us here.
It is just a convention.
The important thing is to be
able to recognize what it takes
for a distribution to
be a Beta distribution.
That this that the dependence
on theta is of the form theta
to some power times 1 minus
theta to some other power.
Any distribution of this form
is called a Beta distribution.
So now, let's
continue this example
by considering a
different prior.
Suppose that the prior is
itself a Beta distribution
of this form where
alpha and beta are
some non-negative numbers.
What is the posterior
in this case?
We just go through the
same calculation as before,
but instead of using one
in the place of the prior,
we now use the prior
that's given to us.
The probability of k
heads in the n tosses,
when we know the bias,
is exactly as before.
It is given by the
binomial probabilities.
And finally, we need to divide
by the denominator term, which
is the normalizing constant.
What do we observe here?
The dependence on theta
comes through these terms.
The remaining terms
do not involve theta,
and they can all be
absorbed in a constant.
Let's call that constant d, and
collect the remaining terms.
We have theta to the
power of alpha plus k,
and then, 1 minus theta to the
power of beta plus n minus k.
And once more, this is
the form of the posterior
for thetas belonging
to this range.
The posterior is 0
outside this range.
So what do we see?
We started with
a prior that came
from the Beta
family of this form,
and we came up with a
posterior that is still
a function of
theta of this form,
but with different values of
the parameters alpha and beta.
Namely, alpha gets
replaced by alpha plus k,
beta gets replaced by
beta plus n minus k.
So we see that if we
start with a prior
from the family of
Beta distributions,
the posterior will also
be in that same family.
This is a beautiful property
of Beta distributions
that can be exploited
in various ways.
One of which is that
it actually allows
for recursive ways of updating
the posterior of Theta
as we get more and
more observations.